[Musique]
je m'occupe des relations je me dirige
la relation publique du Théâtre de Poche
Montparnasse
j'ai eu de en gros trois vies
professionnels puisque j'ai été
infirmière en réanimation pendant une
dizaine d'années tout en faisant un
diplôme de psychopathe psychanalyse
et puis ensuite j'ai été mère au foyer
17 ans et ensuite je suis rentré dans le
monde du spectacle vivant en faisant de
la production de la diffusion
parler du fait qu'on peut changer de vie
professionnelle et par rapport à la
condition des femmes autrefois où ont
finalement soit on travaillait pas soit
on travaillait parce qu'on était obligé
quand moi j'étais jeune
on faisait un métier à la limite entre
guillemets on pensait que c'était pour
la vie et finalement de mon âge j'ai 60
je vais avoir 67 ans il y a peu de il y
a peu de
personnes qui ont eu plusieurs métiers
c'était impensable le but c'était
d'avoir un seul métier de le voilà et
moi-même je n'y pensais même pas quand
j'ai commencé
[Musique]
ce qui va être amené et forcément avoir
plusieurs métiers dans la vie mais de
voir que c'est tout à fait possible et
que si on suit un peu ces passions mais
il faut quand même avoir une assise
financière derrière avoir une
possibilité de trouver du travail
puisque il faut vivre mais après on peut
justement faire fructifier ses passions
et l'important c'est c'est dans la voir
surtout
[Musique]